okay so here we are eating your feet
this is Annie and I'm Nikki our best
friend Adam has challenged us to
recreate black ice cream in a black
waffle cone
and it's based off of this viral video
we tried Instagram famous gothic ice
cream are you a goth wish so the ice
cream is from this place called little
damage in downtown LA yeah it really is
black so it is just soft-serve it comes
out of a soft-serve machine but they put
sprinkles on it can we get sprinkles
yeah it says it's vanilla rose flavor
but it's infused with activated charcoal
so I did a little bit of research
there's this video called Pro tips how
to make soft-serve ice cream at home
from silver magazine this guy Chris
Young makes ice cream using dry ice and
I think he puts it in the freezer for a
little while too to make sure that all
of it sublimates
what does that mean snow and ice
changing into water vapor in the air
without first melting into water so his
recipe is mostly milk with a little bit
of cream sugar salt and vanilla I also
don't know what dry ice solid carbon
dioxide I'm really bad at science
yeah so our expert and other best friend
and third Asian woman with short hair 3a
is here agent Powerpuff Girls we're
making soft-serve ice cream that is
infused with activated charcoal when you
using dry ice don't touch me it's bare
hands
yeah few lies our ingredients it's more
difficult to make this is a lot of it so
you should be fine thanks for you thank
you bye okay
so let's go get our stuff yeah all right
we got
dry-ice my milk powder and what milk but
we could not find rosewater I got stuff
are you okay this function like I don't
think so it burns a little bit well we
have dry ice 12 pounds of it
it's sublimating okay we got to put this
in the freezer so first we should make
waffles we're just making waffle batter
for the LOX and we need to make a black
with the charcoal which we had shipped
to us because I guess it's hard to find
oh okay can you somehow get those into
this ball how much I don't know oh okay
well that's the charcoal shweet tastes
it it's just a powdery substance I got
the oil and the eggs did you get the
water you tell I don't make anything you
couldn't put it in America that's it
oils why does it smell like cake yeah
okay now time to add the charcoal that's
less add it gradually yes to see how
that goes
yeah this does not look like a thing you
should eat more
it might get darker when it cooks I'm
gonna get food coloring just to be safe
yeah let's add a couple drops I don't
know how many we'll find out this is our
waffle cone maker and then it also came
with this thing which I guess is like
after it bakes it'll come out and still
be warm and then you can mold it into
this shape should we get a baking tray
for them when they're done oh yeah put
one show in each Bowl she does stuff
kind of weird but I like it
oh it's green okay ready come on yeah
good when do we open it let's check on
it
Oh turn brown yeah it's hardening oh do
we put it in so no we don't put it in I
don't think it's big enough oh I ripped
them is it too hot we got to do low and
slow
it's not black it's blue why is it blue
so we added a ton more charcoal yes
we'll see if it's dark enough so let's
try a minute I turn to the color control
down which I don't know what exactly
that does but I am assuming it'll make
it less proud Oh better yes oh not that
it's not that it's just very very soft
okay it's premature screaming oh oh it's
hot
oh the tip is open it's fine yeah little
dry bottom first one and our second one
the color is definitely better okay so
it's not baked enough I just don't want
it to turn brown okay that was 2 min it
so let's do 2 and a half I don't think
it was quite big enough Chris maybe our
batter is too thick okay so it's not
really getting crispy but I also don't
want to turn up the color control on the
waffle maker because I don't want it to
be brown on the outside so we're gonna
send out the batter with a little bit of
water everything at the end of the day
it's just gonna be black oh but it's so
crispy so fast okay but better oh oh
let's cook time thin batter is better oh
pretty good so I think we're getting the
hang of the crispy texture but they
still don't look as black as they do in
the video so I wonder if for the rest of
our batter we'll just dump more charcoal
in there okay if this doesn't make a
very dark black hole cone I don't know
what will oh good yes oh that feels
great
ah oh this one's so good there look I
have a black beak you know how much I
love cross we have six usable cones
what's the definition of usable they're
cones
this is our hero cone just beautiful
drink break yeah but you make it for me
okay well I figured since we have all of
this charcoal and I thought it would be
fun to try a White Russian but with a
twist and use chuckle and then it'll be
like black and white
boo-ki okay so we're gonna start with
ice
hmm finger ice this is a drink making
things a little measuring thing yeah
it's gonna measure our booze for us
one and a half ounces of Smirnoff vodka
mmm what makes White Russians kind of
visually cool is how the milk kind of
mixes with the coffee liquor well what
we're gonna do is mix the charcoal with
the coffee liqueur and then it's gonna
be black oh it looks evil the top of a
white Russian is cream so we're gonna do
an ounce and a half a cream Wow BAM look
at how cool that looks there we go black
and white Russian with charcoal Cheers
Adam I mean like this is kind of you as
a drink goes with your outfit yeah now
it's time to make ice cream we got to
get moving pretty quickly here cuz our
dry ice is out and it will help you mate
so we're gonna put it into this bag and
then crush it with the rolling pin the
bag broke ah I forgot the ball okay
so we're gonna go ahead and use Chris
Young's recipe from that server magazine
video the only thing we're changing is
we're adding charcoal a thousand grams a
home a hundred grams I'm a heavy cream
Tohno 25 grams of sugar do you want to
do 3.5 grams of salt this is 95 grams
it smells like farts I'm scooping out
the vanilla and the vanilla bean and we
could not find rosewater so we're not
doing that well I'm gonna get some
vanilla I don't think this is gonna be
enough is that it set all the
ingredients all right let's winter up
they say to be well incorporated before
we add the dry ice
I don't understand what I'm looking at
it looks like a cauldron full of like
bad stuff yeah waters your enemies it's
getting close to the car it looks like
we put a curse on it oh very cool we're
doing something right we're almost there
yeah yeah yeah we're almost there okay
this definitely looks closer to an ice
cream texture because the point is to
freeze it while it's turning so become a
soft but still creamy what happens if
you eat the dry ice like if the chunks
are today we could kill all our
coworkers we've definitely made progress
oh god it's having a hard time oh it's
so frozen at the bottom that's what it
is it is a little icy but I don't know
if stirring it more will help
it's kind of weird what the flavors
supposed to be no I would not eat this
we're making another batch
I saw another chefsteps video where the
guy blends the ice cream base first so
that it's really well incorporated I
also think it'll help dissolve the milk
powder a little better cuz we think
that's what makes it taste kind of funky
we'll do that and we'll blend the
charcoal in so we're not just like
tossing that in too late okay
I'm gonna blend it up Wow this is very
nice this is a high-tech one
okay I don't know
yeah that's blended to me chuckles so
weird look at that phone also I think
last time because we didn't have enough
dry ice and we had to like stop true I
feel like we need to continuously just
incorporate it I think this will be
better than the first time I guess like
soft-serve machines are just always
turning right that makes them
there's definitely less screaming stuff
that makes me a little sad so we're
about ten minutes in the mixing we've
put a lot of dry ice in it definitely
looks thicker oh it does taste different
yeah did it punch you in the back of the
throat it definitely still kids I know
but it's better okay let's get some
piping bag so this set in the freezer
for a few minutes definitely looks like
it's solidified still looks a little
like goopy looks like tentacles also our
friends are here to make me nervous
hey we're here to make you nervous when
it's the critical moment yeah the soft
wasn't issues the tip is you supposed to
bent them before you say but and then
yeah this is very cool okay your places
Wow
yeah yeah much is your outfit yeah that
sprinkles all right good
why is i carbonated that's right it
tastes carbonated because we used dry
ice it is ice cream I think so
yeah and you made the cones too we did
make the cones oh this is the best one
Annie we did it I didn't mention this
throughout the entire video but I'm very
like this impossible so we have black
charcoal waffle cone and then charcoal
vanilla soft serve ice cream good tastes
like it's sour but it's not like that
that were it up this one's for Adam keep
going keep going
okay the task was to make charcoal
waffle cones and charcoal ice cream we
succeeded yeah are you gonna leave with
that have fun and this has been eating
your feet
[Music]
oh yes